[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара вабалола Ласкаво просимо до ефіру
життя в зоні бойових дій люди У деяких
частинах України пристосовуються до
повсякденного життя у містах селищах
понівечених війною поблизу лінії фронту
доступ до чистої води важке завдання
труби в будинках зруйновані дзеркало і
Стілець стають імпровізованою перукарнею
а бункер перетворюється на пральню
мешканці пристосовуються щоб вижити
доступ до таких базових речей як вода
електрика та опалення головні пріоритети
ще один дорогоцінний скарб в Україні це
кохання ви можливо здивуєтесь дізнавшись
що після вторгнення Росії кількість
весіль в Україні почала зростати перед
обличчям життя і смерті українські пари
промовляють так для декого одруження дає
надію на краще майбутнє незважаючи на
постійні атаки з боку Росії запеклі бої
точаться на сході України де Кремль
розпочав потужний наступ у місті Лиман
ми зустріли пару яка Знайшла своє
кохання на лінії фронту
у квітні 2019 року люди в усьому світі
затамували подих коли побачили як
нотр-дама охопила полум'я і він майже
згорів до тла протягом століть собор був
Центральною визначною пам'яткою Парижа
пошкодження яких зазнав готичний шедевр
були величезними і мільйони людей
пожертвували гроші на його відбудову
Сотні мистецтвознавців І ремісників
працюють у день і вночі аби вкластися у
терміни перед відкриттям майстриня зі
скла флаві вінсем пеці одна із таких їй
доручено повернути нотр-даму блиск але
місцевим жителям і туристам доведеться
почекати до кінця наступного року щоб
побачити собор у його колишній красі
флаві ретельно готується до свого
робочого дня
вона майстриня зі скла одна з ремісників
яким доручено відновити вітражі щоб
постраждали під час пожежі у нотрдамі та
очистити їх від кіптяви
це копітка робота але вона йде повним
ходом щоб собор міг якнайшвидше знову
відкритися
[музика]
саме тому люди тут працюють у дві зміни
із 6 ранку до десятої вечора
[музика]
наша робота
з її травми це щось дійсно особливе а
зазвичай ми маємо більше часу для роботи
над проектами які заплановані на довгий
термін але це своєрідна надзвичайна
ситуація нотр-дам має дуже особливу
символічну цінність яку ми повинні
відновити
дивовижним чином більше частина вітражів
собору витримала жар і полум'я пожежі 15
квітня 2019 року
а от культовий Шпиль упав
дах і частина склепіння були зруйновані
весь собор опинився на межі обвалу
після пожежі французький уряд оголосив
про амбітний план реконструкції
нотр-дам мав бути відремонтований і
знову відкритий протягом 5 років і
виглядати ще величніше ніж раніше
на такому важливому будівельному
майданчику повинні працювати тільки
найкращі
при прийомі на роботу ми відібрали
найдосвідченіших майстрів у кожній
професії
у реконструкції беруть участь понад сто
компанії і більше тисячі майстрів
не всі з них працюють на майданчику
ремісникам з усієї Франції доручили
відремонтувати вікна собору
у тому числі флаві Вінсент потіє яка
працює в труах на південь від Парижа
в основному вона працює над вітражами 19
століття хоча деякі з них датуються і
середньовіччям без вітражів собор не
зможе відкритися знову
цих вікон втрачається священна атмосфера
і стає якось померському
вікна - Це фільтри які перетворюють
природне світло на божественне
Шпиль собору теж відновлять точнісінько
таким яким він був раніше
на симетровій висоті дерев'яний Шпиль
знову зніметься у паризьке небо Ми вже
давно не робили Нічого подібного ми
використовуємо техніку яку
використовував архітектор ХІХ століття
віолет Дюк
знаходимося як
реконструкція триває трохи довше ніж
планувалося спочатку
відкриття нотр-даму заплановане на
кінець наступного року
хоча відвідувачі не можуть зайти
всередину вони у захваті від будівельних
робіт
таку будівлю просто необхідно побачити
вона дивовижна
Я радий бачити що вони відбудовують
собор
побачимо чи буде будівля виглядати так
само як оригінал чи навіть краще
ви ж на робота я обов'язково приїду
подивитися на собор коли його відновлять
гроші не проблема для парафії собору
пожертви з усього світу покриють
вартість ремонтних робіт для багатьох
майстрів Це більше ніж просто робота це
справа життя ми частина довгої династії
склобів яка зародилась і ще в
середньовіччі кожен із нас доклав зусиль
щоб зберегти цю будівлю для наступних
поколінь
після того як кіптєву і багатовіковий
пил буде очищено вітражі засяють як нові
і нотр-дам можливо навіть стане трохи
красивішим ніж був раніше
[музика]
жити на березі моря мрія багатьох
любителів природи а для однієї сім'ї в
Британії вона стала реальністю без
зайвих витрат у них є Ферма на узбережжі
Уельсу громаді ньюпорт
посеред національного парку ця ідея
підтримується урядонуельсу але є підступ
метеоткінсон і його дружина керріс
погодились на життя з мінімальним
впливом на навколишнє середовище Просте
життя яке потребує багато уяви
так
О там є це ми теж візьмемо
[музика]
Ельза і білі збирають яйця
їхній батько метіоткінсон здійснив свою
мрію він і його сім'я почали усе із
чистого аркуша
миттю покинув роботу ветеринара як і
його дружина керіс
тепер вони господарюють на невеликому
клаптику землі у Нью порції Уельс
[музика]
де їхній будинок має краєвид на воду
для тих у кого є трохи уяви існує безліч
можливостей і способів щоб сказати Я
хочу спробувати щось інше І це було саме
таким шляхом
ми просто хотіли дати волю творчості та
уяві і перетворити голі овечу поля на
щось сповнене життя
откінсони живуть тим що дає природа
їхній будинок повністю відключений від
електромережі замість пральної машини у
них саморобний пристрій і зручним
приводом
невеликий вітряк і сонячні батареї дають
електрику але в тиху або хмарну погоду
електроенергії може не вистачити
[музика]
усе їм провізоване і все переробляється
навіть старі автомобілі
[музика]
сюди Ми висаджуємо все наше насіння тут
ми його пророщуємо
а тут у нас запасна спальня на випадок
якщо приїжджають друзі чи родичі
ми почали з фургона для коней це
здавалося найшвидшим способом створити
придатний для життя простір
Нам потрібно було трохи більше місця і
ми вирішили що візьмемо кілька старих
сільськогосподарських причепів
прилаштуємо їх ззаду якось з’єднаємо
обшиємо деревом і ось що вийшло
повне міщанина з усього що ми змогли
знайти тоді
овочі ростуть у старих шинах від
вантажівок зараз зима але ревінь уже
проростає Вони вирощують фрукти та овочі
без пестицидів і дбають про збільшення
біорізноманіття на своїй ділянці уряду
ельсу підтримує такі екологічні проекти
У рамках програми розвиток єдиної
планети натомість уоткінсони повинні
продемонструвати що вони самі можуть
забезпечити собі щонайменше 65% їжі та
енергій щоб заробити гроші вони
проводять курси для людей які хочуть
вести спосіб життя Із низьким впливом на
навколишнє середовище вони також
сподівалися розводитиме доносних бджіл
Але це виявилося складнішим ніж вони
думали
бджоли були великою частиною того чим ми
тут займалися ми просто не отримуємо
стільки меду скільки думали чи пов'язано
Це зі змінами клімату теплі вологи зими
які здається стають дедалі частішими і
дуже погано впливають на бджіл Я не знаю
але ми просто щасливі що вони живі і
дуже раді що тепер у нас є бджілки біля
кухонного вікна
щоб отримати і підтримувати статус Еко
піонерів потрібно зробити чимало
паперової роботи щороку Влада перевіряє
чи дійсна сім'я настільки самодостатня
як того вимагають правила Від цього
залежить дозвіл на будівництво
національному парку
щоб показати який ваш екологічний слід
Ви повинні буквально записувати Все на
що витратили гроші усю їжу будь-які
канцтовари одяг із секонд-хенду новий
одяг взуття просто абсолютно все
от кінсу Нам дозволили будувати на
узбережжі у національному парку вони
отримали дозвіл тому що відповідали
суворим екологічним критеріям Вони
живуть на горі карнінглі місцеві жителі
кажуть що це чарівне місце і дехто проти
того щоб опткінсони жили там
коли була подана заявка на участь у
програмі розвиток єдиної планети Це було
дуже емоційне питання тому що карніглі
дуже поважають і шанують місцеві жителі
і багато людей вважає що будь-яка форма
розвитку на силах карлінги неприпустимо
готкінсони живуть тут уже шість років
але тепер їхні сусіди намагаються
заблокувати під’їзну доріжку до будинку
такого вони не очікували
найважче напевно мати справу з опором
тому що ти віриш
я вірю в те що ця ділянка землі стане
більш придатною для життя людей і диких
тварин
от кінсони обходяться беззручностей які
багато хто сприймає як належне життя в
їхніх переобладнаних трейлерах схоже на
сільське особливо вологими зимовими
вечорами але їм тут подобається і вони
хочуть бути прикладом для своїх дітей Ми
маємо набагато менший вплив на
навколишнє середовище живучи так а це
показує їм як вони можуть робити це в
майбутньому І що ми можемо робити це не
відмовляючись від електрики телебачення
та інтернету у нас усе це ще є але ми
можемо без цього обійтися
навіть якщо деяких сусідів не вдалося
переконати откінсона сподіваються що
вони надихнули Якомога більше людей жити
в гармонії із природою
[музика]
підгузки дитяче харчування одяг та
іграшки Ось що у цих пакунках Аїда
садікович засновниця благодійної
організації яка допомагає матерям з
немовлятами у скруті Вони знаходяться в
Боснії та герцеговині одні з найбідніших
країн Європи
рівень безробіття високий а пандемія
погіршила ситуацію особливо у сільській
місцевості де мами з немовлятами не
можуть забезпечити навіть найнеобхідніше
для сімей які живуть у бідності пожертви
стають рятівним кругом
маленька моїда голодна вона третя дитина
меріси ахметович Вони ж чоловіком
нервіном живуть у Боснії і зараз
безробітні часто вони навіть не уявляють
як їм вдасться вижити один боснієць
дозволяє їм жити у своїй квартирі але їм
все одно не вистачає на життя
ми отримуємо допомогу на дітей в
еквіваленсі близько 150 євро на місяць
Це набагато менше ніж їм потрібно зараз
усе дорожчає
сім'ї потрібна приблизно у 4 рази більше
сума щоб звести кінці з кінцями
Аїда садіковичу збирається навідати
родину
їй потрібно Близько трьох годин на
дорогу через гори Взимку коли дороги
погані це ще довше але допомога яку
надає її організація вкрай необхідна на
бідному сході країни
у нас небагато але ми намагаємося
охопити усю боснію Ігор цеговину У нас є
різні проекти а також ми забезпечуємо
всіх куточки країни експрес-поштою і
багато чого ми доставляємо самі ми в
дорозі майже щодня
організація яку заснувала Аїда садіковіч
називається зроби когось щасливим і це
саме те чим вона займається
сім'я ахметовичів - це класичний випадок
сім'я в селі
вони хочуть працювати але роботи немає
ні в приватному ні в державному секторі
Тому їм нічого не залишається крім як
займатися сезонними роботами влітку
збирати малину або працювати в полі
зима для них найгірший час
вони нічого не заробляються витрачають
усі свої літні заощадження щоб пережити
зиму
гуманітарна допомога така як дитяче
харчування одяг і підгузки дуже важливо
Мама дивись у нас є одноразові підгузки
третього розміру Поглянь
чудово третій розмір Чудово прекрасно
піди Подивися як там малюк вдома у
Сараєво Аїда пояснює чому вона щодня
їздить по всій Боснії
спочатку вона вивчала літературу і
вчилася на медсестру але коли сім років
тому у неї народився син заїд Вона
зрозуміла що означає піклуватися про
немовля вона побачила як важко
доводиться матерям із її оточення і
вирішила діяти
Олена заснували нашу першу групу у
Фейсбуці ми допомагали одній дитині на
місяць у вільний час ми збирали все що
могли тільки для цієї дитини
потім про це розповіли кілька
телеканалів і раптом нам почали
телефонувати мами які опинилися в
скрутному становищі а також люди яких
хотіли допомогти немовлятам
сьогодні в організації допомоги працює 5
штатних співробітників значну частину
роботи зі збору речей виконують інші як
наприклад у цьому дитячому садку у
Сараєво Діти принесли речі для
пожертвування допомагати іншим може бути
весело
я пожертвував іграшки щоб у дітей було
те чого у них інакше не було б
[музика]
щоб вони могли розважатися і бути
щасливими
я захотіла пожертвувати кілька речей
тому що у цих дітей нічого немає
і я не хочу аби вони сумували через те
що у них драний одяг чи щось подібне
ми знаємо що у Боснії є багато
благодійних організацій
але ця зосереджена на немовлятах адже
вони найбезпорадніше з усіх І звісно на
інших дітях Минулого року ми налагодили
з ними співпрацю
сьогодні зробив когось щасливим
регулярно допомагає понад двом стам 57
Аїда сидікович каже що держава просто не
в змозі надати допомогу якої так гостро
потребують діти якби не приватні
ініціативи подібні до цієї становище
боснійських дітей було б ще більш
відчайдушним після розпаду його славії
та війни у Боснії майже 30 років тому
економіка країни перебуває у кризі
повернімося до родини ахметовичів
радісно обличчя дітей меріси виправдовує
всі зусилля
Панда приносить більше щастя ніж Промінь
сонця у похмурий зимовий день а це за
словами аїди найголовніше
німецький гурт Rammstein відомий своїми
кінематографічними відеокліпами які
викликають справжні фурок спецефекти і
трюки хореографічно поставлені щоб
створити візуальний шедевр для глядача
Тож як вони знімають у бурхливих водах
не виходячи в море відповідь можна
знайти у бельгійському місті віллорди
неподалік від столиці брюсселя тут
знаходиться найбільша і найсучасніша в
Європі Підводна кіностудія одним
натисканням кнопки створюються крихітні
бриджі або величезні Цунамі і Адреналін
вирує в крові
водні зйомки можуть виглядати елегантно
легкими але вони потребують багато
зусиль як фізичних так і професійних у
вілворди Бельгія - це свого роду
спеціалізація і вони навіть мають
найсучаснішу підводну кіностудію у світі
10 метрів глибини підлога під водою та
обладнання для створення спецефектів
його створив кіно оператори diver який
втомився чекати на сприятливу погоду
[музика]
іноді є буквально днями сидів у воді
чекаючи непотрібний ефект і я побачив
навколо себе команду з 50 людей яка
стояла і чекала Я подумав так не
годиться потрібно придумати щось краще
так з'явилася студія Light Studios
ззовні Вона може виглядати непримітною
але всередині все готове до зйомок
шедеврів кіноіндустрії прямо зараз вони
демонструють на що здатен басейн
він може здійсняти шторми з метровими
хвилями і проливним дощем і Тут
збираються каскадери кращі з кращих
[музика]
знаходитеся там серед хвиль нелегко Адже
ти думаєш що можеш піднятися щоб
ковтнути повітря а тут хвиля б'є тебе в
обличчя і ти намагаєшся вдихнути але
навколо лише вода
тоді потрібно зберігати спокій на
майданчику дуже вітряно і шумно і хвилі
доволі високі тут не лише маленькі хвилі
не лише тихо вода а й великі гребені
проте яких неможливо пливти
Тож ви можете собі уявити наскільки
неспокійна Вода може лякати акторів
звісно усіх спецефектори ретельно
контролюються і є багато персоналу який
слідкує за безпекою але не можна обійти
той факт що в басейні олімпійського
розміру знаходиться 6 мільйонів літрів
води вона нагрівається за допомогою
сонячних панелей і теплових насосів а
температура води становить 32 градуси за
Цельсієм Це добре для довгих днів зйомок
але все одно не легко
ми готуємо акторів покращую випадку ми
зустрічаємося з акторами до початку
зйомок вчимо їх техніці затримки дихання
надовго спокійно поводження у воді а
також основам підводного плавання
дихання під водою за допомогою
регулятора
ви виграєте багато часу що добре
підготують акторів тому що в більшості
дуже важко приїхати сюди працювати в
такому водному середовищі
це складно
багато міжнародних проектів уже побували
на майданчику у вілворди
згодом глядачі навіть не
здогадуватимуться що актори насправді не
в океані
усе це частина магії створення кіно а на
цьому тижні це все до зустрічі у
наступному випуску У фокусі Європа
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]